- Oh my gosh.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- [Kelly] Woo!
Oh my God.
- Energy energy!
I love it.
- I know.
They've got energy.
- Yeah!
- [Kelly] You look so rock and roll.
Me and my friends have decided
you're one of my new favorite people
I've ever met on the planet.
Like I think you're so --
- I love that.
I appreciate that.
'Cause I'm crazy about you.
- I love
like hanging with you last time.
And then we ran into
each other at the Emmys
and we were just passing
and your energy
(Angela laughs)
is just like . . . .
It just exudes from your pores
and it's just like such a light.
And you look stunning
at the Emmys by the way.
- Thank You.
(audience claps)
Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- I was like --
- [Angela] Thank you.
Well, you give energy for energy,
so I love that.
- Oh man!
- [Angela] I got chills right now.
- I love you.
And congrats on your 25th anniversary.
- Thank You.
- That's incredible.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- And I saw a video.
- Um-hm.
- Like I feel like
Courtney has another job
that he could do.
Like party planning should be his,
event planning should be his thing.
That was quite the party.
- It was quite the extravaganza.
- I don't even know if I've been
to a party like that.
- It was (laughs).
I know I hadn't.
- [Kelly] I was like . . . .
- It was an event.
- What?
You walk in,
there were chandeliers gracing!
I was like, "What?"
And then y'all were dancing all,
woo!
You are so sexy.
I was just like, "whatever."
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
I was like...
- It was such a big thing.
- It was a surprise.
He planned all that.
I was out the country working
during the summer
and then I came back
and I happened to be
walking in the backyard.
And it was torn up.
Dirt everywhere.
It was just mayhem.
It was crazy.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And I was like,
"What the heck is going..."
Of course that's a very nice word.
- heck is going on here?
- Yeah.
- He was like, "You weren't
supposed to go back...."
I wasn't supposed to go in the....
No one told me I wasn't
supposed to go in the backyard.
What is going on?
Why do we want, you know?
So I just had to hmm,
so we could make it to 26.
(both laughing)
(audience laughing)
- That's incredible though.
It was such a,
what a beautiful thing to do for someone!
Like has he upped the ante?
Like, are you planning for the . . . .
What are y'all doing for the next one?
He's upped the ante for him
for the next one for me.
- Is he more the planner in that sense?
- He's more the planner.
- I'm not really good at that either.
It's funny, I'm good at
doing that for other people,
but not like when the event is about me.
I feel like 'cause we
always go to events, maybe?
- It's because I'm too frugal.
- I'm too frugal.
- Oh.
(Angela laughs)
- I don't have that problem.
- You saw the chandeliers right?
I go, "What!"
(audience laughs)
- I did see the chandeliers!
- A couple candles!
(Angela laughs)
I was like, "Dang!"
- But I'm not --
- Strike matches.
(both laugh)
(audience laughing)
- That's amazing.
And you've lasted 25 years.
You're still doing it.
(Angela laughs)
That's amazing.
All right.
The emergencies on
"911" get very creative.
So how is season six going?
- It's going pretty well.
I mean we got one that's coming up.
You know a lot of people believe
in coincidences.
- Yeah.
- And curses and stuff like that.
So that's a real fun one
that we have coming up.
- Oh I like that.
- And what do you do?
- Like superstitious almost?
- What do you do?
- Yeah.
I personally
don't believe in coincidence.
- You don't?
- I love that saying,
it's too coincidental
not to be intentional.
(Angela laughs)
- Oh, I've never heard that.
- Yeah.
- Put that on a bumper sticker.
I've never heard that.
Well after six seasons,
it's incredible the writers coming up
with all these different things
that you're going through.
That's incredible first of all.
But do you feel like you're more prepared
for a real life emergency
after doing the show for six seasons?
- Absolutely, positively not.
- What?
(audience laughs)
- No, I'm still scary.
- I feel like
that's a bit of a failure.
(Kelly laughs)
- I'm still scary.
We've had,
especially when we get
around that Halloween
season and all of that.
I don't like Halloween.
I don't like scary movies.
- You don't?
- I don't like to be,
I don't like scary movies,
but I like dressing up.
I like a costume party
- Okay.
That's okay.
- Yeah.
No that's all I'm into.
I don't like
like horror things
or like haunted,
what are,
houses that you go.
Nah, that's not my thing.
- Jumping out at you.
- People pay people for people
to run after 'em with an ax.
I'm like, what's that?
Are you outta your mind?
(audience laughs)
Yeah, I don't get that either.
- Ah yeah.
I make the biggest fool.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping and cheering)
So you got twin 16 year olds at a home,
so they're start to drive right now?
- Yes and that's another scary thing.
They love being scared.
So them driving is scary.
I literally last weekend
just took my daughter
to get her driver's permit.
- Oh man.
- And I guess he got his
about two months previous.
So I've taken her on one drive.
I've taken him on about three drives.
- Wait, do you do better with him or?
- Maybe because he's had three drives.
So I think with each drive
a little confidence builds.
- Yeah.
- But I know
I won't be teaching them parallel parking
because I'm not so good
at that myself.
- Oh, I love it.
- You do?
- I could teach your kids
to parallel.
- Can you?
- You see that truck out there, girl?
That's me.
(audience laughs)
I parallel.
I'm like boop boop.
I get it done in two things.
Don't even worry about it.
Yeah.
- I got something in my car
that says Parallel Assist.
So if I could figure it out,
- Naw.
- I can push the button
and just take my hands off
and it'll parallel park
by itself.
- I love parallel parking.
- But you gotta know how
to do it for yourself.
- Yeah, no, that's true.
I'm terrified for my kids to drive though
because I'm more terrified
of other drivers.
- Same.
- Yeah.
- I think my kids are gonna be all right
and like responsible,
but I'm more worried about other drivers.
- I think they'll be okay.
- Yeah.
- But it's the others, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Speaking of your kids though,
is it true that you had
them break a family rule
when the first "Black Panther" came out?
- Oh yeah.
That was worth it.
- So what was the family rule?
They weren't allowed to ...
- Well you know,
they're so impressionable.
- Yeah.
- And you get a lot of perks
and entree and all of that.
- Heck yeah.
- in Hollywood being in the business
that we are.
- Yeah.
- And it's not for them.
- So it's,
you want them to be normal,
have a normal childhood
- Um-hm.
- and also work hard for the things,
you know.
- Yeah.
- Work hard period.
- Like we did.
- Yeah.
And nothing beats that.
And so we wouldn't,
Courtney took it so far like,
"Nope, we're gonna drive them.
They're not driving in
limos or cars to places,
to the airport.
Just bring a regular old little car."
You know, that sort of thing.
But when "Black Panther" came
and just the representation
that it offered,
we thought it was very important
- Oh my God super cool.
- to see that on the screen.
Superhero.
The audiences that were there.
- Queens kings that's cool.
- And also just to get
a little love from kids
'cause a lot,
maybe your kids are still in love,
still in awe of you.
- But at one point,
- Uh?
- he doesn't wanna hug
and she's like "Mom!"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Sometimes whatever
you can to impress them.
- I'm holding on it.
But speaking of "Black Panther,"
do you feel like the success of a movie
with a largely black cast
has changed Hollywood at all?
Or do you feel,
obviously there's a
ways to go I feel like.
- Always a ways to go.
- Yep.
- Always a distance
we can cover.
- Yeah.
- That's great.
We never get to the end.
- Yeah.
And this perfection,
but there's always this push and pull
and back and forth.
But definitely the success of that movie
over a billion dollars
- Um-hm.
- makes a couple of people
(audience claps)
like uh
- Yeah.
- take a good look.
- You know?
And that old adage we used to hear
about Black movies not
traveling across the seas
in markets, foreign markets
it's not particularly true.
- True yeah.
- So each success
- You wouldn't know
unless you make them yeah.
- breeds success.
- Yeah.
So you had to make "Wakanda Forever"
without Chadwick Boseman.
- Um-hm yeah.
- So did the cast,
was it kind of odd at first?
Did y'all do anything?
- Oh when we arrived on the set,
a couple of days before
reading through and rehearsals and stuff.
It was planned.
The producers and director had planned,
had rented a plane
and we all flew to South Carolina
and we went to visit
together his resting place.
- Wow.
- Together.
And it was a beautiful day.
His uncles were there.
- Wow.
- His cousin.
And we just spoke from our heart about him
how we felt about him
- Yeah.
- or times with him and that
was really, really lovely.
A great way to just begin
because we miss him terribly.
- Yeah.
Then when we got to the set,
it was like,
okay we've had this
moment of coming together
and now we've got to come to work.
And that's what he would want for us.
- I know.
It's so funny.
It feels like the movie.
It feels like that's something
you would've done in Wakanda
like if someone passed.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that feels,
it feels . . . .
I'm such a fan sorry.
Keeping my cool.
I'm like really excited
about the new movie.
So we know a tiny bit of
what happens in the movie
because we have this clip.
(air whooshing)
(door clanging)
♪ Whoo whoo whoo whoo whoo ♪
♪ Whoo whoo ♪
♪ Whoo whoo whoo ♪
♪ Whoo whoo whoo whoo whoo ♪
♪ Whoo whoo ♪
♪ Whoo whoo whoo ♪
♪ Whoo whoo whoo whoo whoo ♪
♪ Whoo whoo ♪
(speaking Xhosa)
♪ Whoo whoo whoo whoo whoo ♪
♪ Whoo whoo whoo ♪
(speaking Xhosa)
- Let our gracious response
to this incursion be an olive branch.
Further attempts on our
resources will be considered
an act of aggression and met
with a much steeper response.